hello Greg hello rejects this is Greg
this is Mona
oh so Mona and I are gonna do a video
today from our friends at top five
unknowns 5-band
disturbing and unexpected moments in kid
shows oh thank God I thought that said
showers in kids showers the most
unexpected thing that happens when a
child is showered that's what this
channel is all about people good
okay Monette you ready ready cheers to
me you're not having it one that these
writers were thinking I coming up with
these scenes furthermore who actually
allowed them to air in today's video we
take a look at some scenes from kids
cartoons that were banned for being
racist or inappropriate okay five all
this and rabbits dude this animated
short was released on September 13th
1941 produced by Warner Brothers and
Vitaphone the animated short has become
one of the cents at 11:00 the censored
11 or group of Looney Tunes and Merrie
Melodies cartoons that were banned from
syndication on United States television
most of the films are banned for the use
of ethnic stereotypes the cartoon
features a black character who's
portrayed as being slow-witted
he traced his box finding around in
hopes of catching him but never doubts
this stereotype is known in Hollywood as
the Coons stereotype has been in use
within print since as early as the 1600s
by the 1800s the stereotype became
common in the minds of Americans and
Hollywood it led to the birth of shows
such as minstrel shows actor step-in
Fetchit made a career using this
stereotype the character Huston in the
cartoon was based on him in the 1930s
Stefan was best known as being the most
successful black actor in Hollywood as
during this time there wasn't many he
became the first black actor to receive
a featured screen credit and also became
a millionaire due to the stereotype he
portrayed his persona became known as
the laziest man in the world this
stereotype was common in film during
this era and has been used in many
productions such as this Betty Boop
cartoon from 1949 stop stop that stop
that there you go oh wow the laziest man
you know what the laziest man in America
is right now these reaction channels we
beat him yeah we don't have to play some
black stereotype monette this is all I
have to do to be winning that title
sitting down here next to a friend
drinking a beer drinking and then I talk
about some [ __ ] I just watch this is
because ya lazy yeah this is I am a
different kind of stereotype I'm an
American stereotype maybe not older
black man
kootz is what they called it that's an
offensive work huh I've never heard that
word before of you know and I don't
think I want to you don't want to be you
don't want to hear that word no on earth
like because I have some black friends
wonder if I've said that word if they
would know it I hope not
we should test them out no maybe not I
did anything I know my black friends
love to be tested out on whether
I am racist or not now is definitely not
the time I'm telling you I got black
subscribers they love it when I try to
like fit in with my home boy I stressed
my chicken biscuits no that's my
commentary laziest man in America right
druggies as we can see from the dragon
drug use as he Boop like the push the
envelope created in the 1930s homemade
audience was men this was until 1934 in
1934 due to the National Legion of
decency production code the writers have
been super told to turn down the
material and make it more child-friendly
Borchetta titled ha ha ha which was
released in 1934 has been banned from
television the episode follows Betty and
a clown known as Coco after Coco gets a
toothache they go to the dentist Betty
struggles to remove the clown's tooth so
she operates a canister of laughing gas
which spreads around the room and makes
everybody act hysterical the clip isn't
marched by still managed to get the
cartoon banned for drug use laughing gas
also known as nitrous oxide is a
chemical compound used by dentists for
its numbing agent it also causes
euphoria laughing gas is commonly used
as a recreational drug and is known as
whippets or balloons oh I've heard of
that Wow
have you tried it no of you yeah you
have oh yeah is it like when they when
you go to the dentist it's like all your
problems go away and then they all come
rushing back once it wears that sounds
well how long does it last for it can
last up to hours depending on how long
you keep it going
the laughing gas thing yeah yeah yeah I
don't know I'm just making all that well
that doesn't seem so bad no but it was a
different time it made me think like
we've come such a long way since
conservative values were so strong and I
really feel like with this new
presidential election that the evolution
of you know what I'm trying to say we're
[ __ ]
American me hi make America hi again
pretty soon like he's gonna ban family
guy for being too offensive
I don't think so I'm telling you the
president has power over everything in
the world if anything he had them play
it double time don't you think
testing like Trump's kind of humor he's
gonna be a great man I feel it you feel
it you know I also feel my shoulders
tightening from saying that fried rabbit
due to the racial moment in this cartoon
it was banned from TV and was to never
be seen again that's TV Internet we're
able to see what caused such a stir this
Looney Toon cartoon was released on May
2nd 1953 ok cartoon features Bugs Bunny
and Yosemite Sam the pair argue about
two different landscapes and Yosemite
believes he is still in the American
Civil War of the late 18-hundreds
therefore as Yosemite believes he is
still part of the South he will not let
Bugs Bunny cross over in true Looney
Tunes fashion this goes on for a while
as they continue to play cat and mouse
as Bugs Bunny comes up with different
disguises in order to cross this is when
the racist moment occurs due to the
Confederate flag being showed and the
fact that Bugs Bunny posed as a slave
the film was banned it can still be
found on some Looney tune VHS collection
tapes number two that was pretty racist
Ellis that was definitely a racist yeah
I would have laughed if I saw that in
the theater though I don't know well
parents would be taking their kids out
to leave I'd be sitting there smoking my
cigar laughing hysterically as I sit
next to Michael Moore eating my popcorn
a bunch of crunch would watch a crunch
yeah the bunch better never mix that
with your popcorn yeah oh no it's
delicious no dad I'm telling you you're
gonna love it yeah got it kid
I got try that uh yeah I feel like the
Looney Tunes alike have so many episodes
at a probably didn't band they were like
our family guy hey not like their family
guy
yeah that's so crazy and yet it's still
so popular it's still so popular yeah
that's a lot more child friendly than
the cartoons that we have now I don't
know as much as I like to talk like I
love them I don't really know the Looney
Tunes as well as I hope I did I think I
used to um I've moved on since then I
just wish they had that black character
back that we saw on number five Oh No
Looney Tunes perfect major Cleveland you
need your token black character it makes
any movie work this is so uncomfortable
one chicken lesbian joke 0:01 kids
cartoon remember the show least in 1997
the main character yes all known as the
cow and the chicken head assembly bonus
like an annoying so I hiked with Buffalo
gals originated but internship 1998 was
quickly pulled from air and banned from
syndication in the episode the Buffalo
gals arrive at the Jewish household they
then start supports quite a disturbance
and begin to start chewing on carpet in
the episode the Buffalo gals are
described as a motorcycle riding gang
that randomly break into people's homes
and chew on their carpets obvious
release Cartoon Network banned the
episode and removed it from syndication
well I moved it due to the innuendos
implying the Buffalo gals we're lesbians
and stereotypes used to represent
lesbians number one like what they have
no examples
whether they were tough that they could
break in they could take what they want
you mean a self empowered woman I think
that would have been powerful I think a
lot of young women like women at your
age in 1997 or 80
how would you have been oh wow one
negative you're like 13 years old I
don't know it didn't seem that offense
I'm what kid's gonna watch that and be
like yeah seems like a bunch of lesbians
I don't think so I think it's just the
parents that are like oh yeah this is
what they're thinking way too much about
it like dude chill out I got the parents
secretly wanted to do it first
the Japanese Popeye the sailorman most
of us probably know
this is originally featured in a comic
strip in 1929 since then Popeye has been
animated in 1942 or Popeye cartoon was
released titled your ass at mr. Jack Oh
Popeye single-handedly defeating a
battleship filled with Japanese soldiers
the Pearl Harbor attack carried out by
the Japanese was still quite relevant by
the time that animation was released the
Japanese characters were joining
caricature style and some scenes showed
their officers committing suicide the
cartoon was banned as people found it
racially offensive it stayed banned
until two karakurt committed suicide the
cartoon was banned as people found it
racially offensive it stayed banned
until 2008 when it was released but this
time it was edited to take out the
offensive part due to the time period
this stereotype was used in many other
cartoons such as the Looney Tunes
animation polluted Tokyo Tokyo this was
dedicated to world war ii the stereotype
was also used in the Flintstones thank
you so much for watching
who controlled the video then be sure to
give it a big thumbs subscribe to top
five unknowns people worth while anyway
that that one was racist well they're
all they're all racist some of them are
like you read too much into it yeah this
is or like with Betty Boop
what's her name it's let's keep it Betty
Boop
Betty Boop that wasn't that bad but that
was like super olive super why right why
why are people even making that that's
because I guess they're taking a stand
against like what happened at Pearl
Harbor so they thought it'd be cool to
do like hardcore let's draw them like
the most stereotypical like what was
that one movie that's considered one of
the most racist performances that oldies
movie I think it was Mickey Rooney who
played him Breakfast at Tiffany's was it
yeah just like put on the may he's a
white guy you put on the makeup to make
himself look Japanese is super
stereotypical oh god that's what that
was like they had them committing
suicide in the episode holy [ __ ]
surprised at that time that that got on
the air at all then before I got bad you
know that's crazy
that's different
a good solution is to make fun of it
through cartoons yes exactly that's
what's wrong with our country cartoons
because the Looney Tunes and all them
did that it took the people who were
kids back then and now those kids
decided to run for president and look
what's become of him anyway subscriber
the real rejects get accepted no-name
Moyo
she's on the channel she has a channel
called sweet eat yum here's how sweets
works people first off mo nets there and
she's great to look at oh and she's got
another friend who's also wonderful look
at on top of that - they're wonderful to
listen to oh thank you looks and
personality Wow awesome and what are
they talking about people they're
talking about how to make healthy food
in a delicious manner healthy baking
primarily and I'm telling you guys it is
a good channel they're witty and funny
and knowledgeable thanks and the food is
super yummy baby that is super yummy
okay but that's your product is the food
but it's you sounds it haha I am there
involve you anyone could do that yeah